welcome back mr. Disney all the Jews
gone yet no put me back it last week on
Larry King Live Marlon Brando made the
shocking statement that Hollywood is
quote run by Jews in response outraged
Jewish organizations made it snow in New
York in April my allergies and
everything else just terrible Jew Jew
all right let's go
what should we leave for a tip the food
and service were both great give him the
full three percent Jew Jew
this is why I hate going outside my
mother is Jewish and my father is
Catholic that is the truth I was raised
Catholic formerly although I must say
the Jewish mind comes out even in the
Catholic system giving example we used
to go into confession and I would bring
a lawyer in with me
bless me Father for I have sinned I
think you know mr. Cohen the setup of
the joke is it's Jew joke okay to a
Gentile businessman meet on the street
one of them says how's business the
other one says great see he gets it you
really got it he really liked it yeah
this is my Jew flattening machine it'll
flatten any Jew simply climb behind the
wheel drive it towards a Jew and flatten
them could you also use it just to drive
from place to place and stuff it's a Jew
flattening machine it's not what it's
designed for but you could use it that
way yeah yeah you could yeah you could
also use the Mona Lisa as a placemat God
well earlier this week actor Marlon
Brando met with Jewish leaders to
apologize for comments he made on Larry
King Live among them that quote
Hollywood is run by Jews the Jewish
leaders accepted the actor's apology and
announced that Brando is now free to
work again
stuff like that
listen stop right there a minute man
goes into a restaurant you listening and
man goes into a restaurant he sits down
he's having a bowl of soup he says to
Nevada Nevada come taste the soup read
says it is something wrong with the
super just tends to soup he says his son
rolled the soup is the soup to Isis will
you taste the soup is running the soup
to Cole where you just taste the soup
all right
I'll taste the soup where's the spoon ha
ha what do you know from funnier best
it's moving day can anything be more
stressful the packing the lifting saying
goodbye to the neighbors why say Oy Vey
when there's a better way chosen people
choose Joo Hong Joo ma should be three
major routes Gaza to Haifa Jerusalem to
Tel Aviv and your plan
don't you all and leave the schlepping
to us Juho relocating Jews for over
5,000 years a group of Orthodox rabbis
declared that other branches of Judaism
are quote not Judaism at all
thus challenging the religious status of
millions of American Jews this week that
statement was rejected by reform leader
rabbi tangshan Steen who said quote our
legitimacy as Jews flows from the
richness of our Jewish lives the
strength of our Jewish communities and
most important of all our deep and
abiding belief in Jesus Christ a Gentile
man calls his mother he's his mom I know
we've been cooking my favorite food all
day long unfortunately something just
came up and I won't be able to make it
to your house for dinner tonight his
mother says okay
[Laughter]
second Gentile joke
a Gentile man goes into a clothing store
says to the clerk
that's a lovely sports jacket how much
is it the clerk says $395 he says fine
I'll take it the third Gentile joke to
Gentile men meet on the street once the
other says together and the same you
have your own business how are things
going the other says terrific thank you
boy you've seen that what's going on in
Israel heartwrenching the soldiers
carrying Jews out of their homes and
hundreds of Jews were screaming they
were screaming you're doing it wrong
lift with your knees I kid the Jews you
know I do know it's very sad they tried
to get they tried everything to get
these people to leave they tried water
cannons they tried Special Forces they
tried wire cutters finally as a last
resort they had a black family move in
next door look at us you know we make a
great team guys like Huey Lewis and the
Jews sorry the beds breaking up finally
folks next week Jews everywhere will be
celebrating the holiday of Yom Kippur or
as non-jews refer to it
weddings day
I can't dissect a pig mr. Kingman it's
against my religion
believe me nail it's no thrill for the
pig to touch a Jew either you know in
religion bashing Jews never get [ __ ]
with because a they don't have the
aggressive recruiting policies that
other religions do they don't have
billboards every 30 feet there be a Jew
or burn in hell do God is watching you
they're not banging on your [ __ ] door
with pamphlets
we were to talk to you about Judaism so
they don't get [ __ ] for that they don't
get [ __ ] because they have that
Holocaust sympathy they can surf on for
another 15 years till the last survivor
dies or History Channel goes out of
business but and the Jews to their
credit they don't have the history of
atrocities that other religions have
they don't because they [ __ ] lost all
the time sorry right but there are yeah
they're not like you know the Muslims
and Catholics I've heard so many comics
doing [ __ ] about this new pope oh isn't
it scary this new pope used to be a Nazi
and ago not when you look at that track
records side by side but Nazis versus
the Catholic Church the Nazis only
lasted a dozen years and they got their
ass handed to him in a high Catholic
Church has been has a far more
prosperous and prestigious record of
murder and torture
nonsense
not to mention the kid [ __ ] and
they're still around more popular than
ever I'd be far more afraid to hear
someone go you know that new Nazi he
used to be a pope dangerous
[Applause]
so [ __ ] the Jews that's what I'm saying
I never said it over the course of my
career but [ __ ] the Jews just for being
a religion at all
you're as complicit as the rest in the
retardation of human intellectual
progress
my brothers of June my brother's a Jew
and I [ __ ] [ __ ] him too I hate his
guts for it hey level but boy what do
you die you think he converted because
the only humorless [ __ ] in his life that
would ever [ __ ] him twice he had a
cave-in and merrier
cuz he's afraid to die alone but but he
doesn't mind settling for Less and now
they're together in a passionless swamp
of a relationship they teach their kids
that [ __ ] see the parents wouldn't have
him if he wasn't converted to Judaism
cuz they're racist and there's another
reason to [ __ ] the Jews I don't like
races but it suits you you're not good
enough if you're not a Jew
mostly I hate the Jews cuz it wicked
annoying can we agree on that
good wicked annoying listen of all the
religions i I've been around the Jews
have a tendency to throw their judaism
into whatever conversation you're having
any topic whatever there's subject well
that's funny cuz I'm a Jew oh I have a
typical Jewish mother and I think grew
up Jewish well I do family jiù jiù jiù
jiù jiù do
two two two two that's all I got to say
juju I Wow look what that what do you
keep saying to why do you keep saying to
I'm at an airport bar with you I have to
talk to you but can you stop reminding
me that you're irrational in every third
sentence it's like it's like people who
are really into their astrological sign
and they have to pitch that you know
whatever conversation you're having to
define themselves
it's funny I'm a Virgo here's my Virgo
coming out again
you're gonna have to excuse me I'm a bit
of a perfectionist it's because I'm a
bird go nuts because you're a douchebag
and you've been busting my balls or some
of the stars it's cuz you're a [ __ ]
and it's time for you to take individual
responsibility for who you are don't act
like if your parents had [ __ ] a month
earlier you'd be feeding me chili dogs
and let them [ __ ] slide you're an
[ __ ]
be who we are but I'm a Jew we naturally
carry a lot of guilt it's a Jewish thing
no it's a you thing you that [ __ ] in
that chair that's nothing to do it cutie
if you have guilt maybe you're weak of
character maybe you're guilty of
something I don't know maybe you just
stole that bottle of Jager on in my
freezer you said it move but it has
nothing to do with some ancient tribe of
blah blah blah that's not attached to
your DNA right by the by by the same
logic we all come from apes but I don't
throw ape in every conversation use
a to define myself use ape as an excuse
to defecate in my thumbless myth did I
just splatter you with wet feces I'm
sorry I have a very rich ate upbringing
a strong 8 heritage a I'm an EP babe
baby baby babe